the dark side of the force is a pathway to
many abilities some consider to be unnatural
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going
to be my mandalorian season 2 video for my top 10
predictions for the finale there's so many big
story lines that they have to wrap up so many big
easter eggs and deep cuts from the legends canon
if you're new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos obviously i will be doing
season three videos because they're going to be
entering production for season 3 really soon
if they haven't already we're doing a giveaway
for disney plus memberships all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave all your
finale predictions on the video so careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen any of the season
2 episodes yet but starting with number 10 mando
will use bill burr's character to track down where
moff getting is hiding where his home base is
in mounts a rescue mission that winds up being
a big reference callback to a new hope when luke
skywalker obi-wan kenobi han solo chewbacca c3po
r2d2 rescued princess leia from the death star
only it's them rescuing grogu from moff gideon the
most obvious references on the show are references
to the original trilogy like we just had all the
boba fett return of the jedi empire strikes back
references during episode six even though there's
no actual death star in this scenario they're not
gonna roll out a fourth version of the death star
in the canon boba fett will probably wind up being
the obi-wan kenobi of the scenario and sacrifice
himself to save mando or seemingly sacrifice
himself if boba fett winds up sacrificing himself
i would expect them to play it the same way they
played his ending in return of the jedi like you
think that he's dead in the moment but really he
wound up surviving because there were rumors that
boba fett would figure into future seasons but i
think that has a lot to do with what's happening
with the boba fett mini series which is actually
a prequel series set earlier in the timeline
i'll explain that at the end of the video too
there is more boba fett stuff happening but
it's during a different part of the timeline but
number nine a lot of you have also guessed this is
also in service of boba fett potentially giving
mando the slave 1 ship to replace the vaporized
razor crest really if you re-watch the explosion
from episode 6 it's more like melted the razor
crest i don't know how they would rebuild that and
mando needs a ship boba fett has a really badass
ship that's gonna sell a ton of toys they've been
doing this big boba fett redemption arc trying to
make him come off much more like a hero than he
has in the past i mean he's a bounty hunter he's
a mandalorian now per cannon they sort of clarify
that and he's lawful neutral the other funny thing
about this too more foreshadowing for future
seasons if you look at the concept art drawings
from the end of episode six you can see the inside
of the slave one it's a really cool concept art
drawing but you notice that there are two hammocks
one right after the other like bunk beds so
there's one for mando and one for grogu when he
eventually winds up getting him back we'll get
to that too because i think there'll be some big
empire strikes back twist during the ending just
a really cool upgraded ship fermando going into
future seasons of the show number eight boca tan
will probably come back to help mando fight moff
gideon with other mandalorians in a super sized
version of the last two mandalorian fight scenes
of them jet packing in like season 1 episode three
they jet pack in their super badass they steamroll
all the other bounty hunters in town then you have
season 2 episode 3 where bo katan and the night
owls mandalorians jet pack in and they're real
badass taking out these other bounty hunters
so just picture some version of that happening
in the finale where they roll in to help out bo
katan was trying to get mando to join the night
owls join their greater cause in retaking the
planet mandalore his whole reason for not doing
that was because he was still quested to take
grogu back to the jedi and he's starting to feel
more like a father to him too so he's starting
to feel more reluctant about letting him go
number seven moff gideon and mando will have
their full blown dark saber fight scene with
mando using the new best scar spear because it's
resistant to lightsaber blades that's what all
those ahsoka tano vs mando scenes were about with
her twin lightsabers not being able to penetrate
his best scar gauntlets there have been a couple
other scenes too where you see him using himself
as a human shield because the blaster fire just
bounces off the best scar it still hurts him but
it bounces off most of you've seen some of my game
of thrones videos even if you didn't watch the
series during game of thrones season 4 he played
oberyn martel the red viper and his trademark
weapon was a giant spear there were all kinds
of behind the scenes featurettes of him using it
training with it so just picture the red viper
versus moff gideon with his dark saber we had him
do wushu classes before he came to us and then
we had a wushu expert fight with him and learn
him about spears to look look sharp i am sure
there are going to be all kinds of memes with him
getting his eyes crushed out i think it's a pretty
safe bet that their fight will not go down the
same way as oprah and martel versus the mountain
went down but i cannot wait to see them throw down
number six grand admiral thrawn will probably
get teased again in a bigger way this time
maybe we even get to see his fleet or see him if
they've already cast an actor they've been pretty
good about keeping that stuff on the dl but i'm
not expecting too much from that they'll probably
save most of the thrawn stuff for future seasons
in the potential ahsoka tano spin-off series
his main ship is a star destroyer called the
chimera he has a fleet of star destroyers so
if we're talking about original trilogy star wars
movie references moff gideon would be the darth
vader to thrawn's emperor you have to imagine
that thrawn is a much more sherlockian villain
much more cerebral much smarter with way bigger
and way more capital ships because there's so
many empire strikes back references during season
2 it was the second movie one of the big reveals
during empire strikes back was that darth vader
was in service of someone even greater even worse
more powerful the emperor and you got to see
him for the first time i've already talked a
little bit about really awesome castings of course
benedict cumberbatch is thrawn would be amazing
but because lars mickelson did his voice on star
wars rebels and he played a sherlock villain
with benedict cumberbatch they could just paint
him blue and it would be just another one of
those katy sakhoff boca tan animation to live
action jumps having the animated voice over actor
play the live action version of their character
because he is a very good very accomplished very
experienced actor but also i expect the socatano
to come back and help mando and grogu in some way
at least some small way before future seasons in
whatever her potential spin-off series might be
there were some interviews that rosario dawson
did after the ahsoka episode that made it sound
like she was coming back before the end of the
season in number five they will tease the new
jedi actually answering grogu's call from episode
six remember he reached out to that beacon in the
force to the entire galaxy that's sort of a plot
device for them to draw on in future seasons
and future story because a number of different
force-sensitive people could show up both good
people and bad people but a lot of us are just
expecting them to get into ezra bridger's story
line especially because of all the ahsoka and the
thrawn stuff that they teased if thrawn came back
from the unknown regions after star wars rebels
when they disappeared in the finale then it's
very logical that ezra also came back and they'll
save a lot of that for potential ahsoka spin-off
series and future seasons of the mandalorian
even if they cover a lot of this storyline on
other spin-off series from the mandalorian all
the characters will still eventually appear on
the mandalorian in some way number four they'll
clarify the relationship between moff gideon and
grand admiral thrawn are they working together
by choice do they hate each other is it more
like darth vader working with the emperor like the
emperor was always trying to undermine darth vader
and keep him under his thumb and darth vader
was trying to do the same thing to the emperor
like he tried to get luke to join him we can
overthrow the emperor and rule the galaxy together
vader was always suspicious of the emperor he was
always looking for an opportunity to get rid of
him he really didn't like him at all but he was
too powerful to confront directly and when it
comes to a lot of the thrawn stuff i talked about
them doing heir to the empire across the new star
wars live-action disney plus series like where you
would have originally expected them to do an heir
to the empire trilogy of movies now they'll borrow
from that storyline and just do that across all
these live-action disney plus series i've already
done a couple videos about thrawn's backstory and
how he figures into this ahsoka tano spin-off
potential series in the teaser from episode five
so i'll post links to that in the description at
the end of this i'm really interested to see how
thrawn translates to the live action series but
number three also big wtf twists are expecting
the home base is going to be something associated
with the planet mandalore itself either they'll
have a base near it or they're using the planet
itself as their actual base but because bo katan's
whole mission is retaking the planet i feel like
they'll tease the planet mandalore in some way
but they won't be able to win it back that'll be
for future seasons because of the full reveal of
moffgetting and grand admiral thrawn's combine
fleets in star destroyers like i said number
two i expect them to end things on a very empire
strikes back style downer cliffhanger moment like
the rumored threat of moff gideon and thrawn's
combined fleets their forces the dark troopers
will get a couple more big reveals and they'll
come off seeming like they're legit invincible
and almost all hope will be lost and they
might not actually be able to rescue grosgu
like ending the season with grogu trying to
sacrifice himself to save mando's life but not
dying grogu is still gonna be a fundamental part
of the show in future seasons i think everyone
would threaten to cancel their disney plus if they
hurt the baby so if anybody is wearing plot armor
in the finale i feel like it's gonna be grogu but
number one also around the finale the star wars
people will release more details on all the other
star wars live action disney plus series including
which mandalorian spin-offs they're actually
doing they already confirmed the prequel boba
fett miniseries i don't know how many episodes
that's going to be but it sounds like they're
going to try and release it sometime later next
year there's a rumored ahsoka tano spin-off series
and there could be other ones that we haven't
heard about yet and they'll reveal more of what's
going on with the obi-wan kenobi series if darth
maul really is going to come back and be a villain
during that in the rogue one series with cassian
andor and some of the other rogue one characters
it's a prequel series so most of those characters
are alive again but not all of them will be on
the tv show and like i said mandalorian season 3
is supposed to be in production sometime between
right now and early next year with them releasing
season 3 episodes around the same time next year
they're on a pretty reliable schedule and the
working title supposedly for mando season 3
is buccaneer which is basically a type of pirate
so think about what kind of imagery that evokes
when you think about star wars space pirates
they've been talking about boca tan during episode
three like she'd been a pirate since the great
purge of the mandalorians so i think we'll see a
lot more of them during season three and obviously
ahsoka tano is always probably gonna come back
but everyone post all your predictions on the
video my full mandalorian season 2 episode 7 video
will post on friday just like normal but i will be
doing bonus videos between now and then so there's
any special mandalorian videos that you want me
to make just let me know in the comments what will
happen after the mandalorian season 2 finale
is that the avengers 1 division episodes will
start up all the marvel big disney plus series
and i'll be doing videos for that too so i'll
talk more about that as they roll out more footage
later this year will you wait for everything click
here for my full mandalorian season 2 episode
6 video and click here for my new mandalorian
grogu luke skywalker video thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe this is the way!